do you think of dating apps do you think
they can be successful I have never had
lots of lots of dating apps partially
I'll tell you why as a girl it's a lot
harder for me to get comfortable with a
guy I feel like we don't have mutual
friends or something I think that's why
I've always gone down that route but it
also kind of limits you because like how
many friends you got yeah yeah and so
I'm open to it but I'm just curious from
a guy's point of view do you feel like
guys on dating apps are are they there
for something serious because it's just
in my head I just imagine no I think
well I think probably a lot of them are
because when you think about it like for
most guys like you talk about you know
gen Zed or Millennials or whatever I
mean that like this is now their only
Outlet really because they don't either
they don't think whole approach is
possible or they think it's uh it's too
intimidating or it may be it you know
it's they shouldn't be doing it because
of society I think there are going to be
some genuine guys on there for sure but
um weeding through the chaff is is it's
a lovely process I mean the thing with
dating apps is for me personally I don't
you like them I never used I very rarely
use them these days I don't I don't
drink and it's like do you feel like
okay you can go because I feel like bars
like those are just guys trying to get
late yeah do you what do you what do you
think like well I don't drink all either
actually so this is something that comes
up a lot because guys actually a guy
just just today message me saying what
would you be doing a date when you don't
drink and those kind of things so it's a
big issue I think getting out into the
market anywhere is a good thing to do
like because that's why I was asking you
know do you presumably you don't go out
much at night because you're doing the
show and everything but if you can if
you could like take one evening a week
and just go to a social place or not
even necessarily like a bar like some
really Rowdy place but maybe somewhere
like Soho house or something like that
it's like a bar club kind of thing but
you you play some membership and you
know and you some people obviously the
other people that remembers as well
somewhere like that might be quite good
but you could just go you can it's a bit
more chilled out it's not like some
crazy party do you recommend because
Kevin Samuels would say women should go
out by themselves if they want to be
approached more do you feel like that's
true we're going out with a friend it
probably is true that if you're on your
own you you might get approachable but
then at the same time do you really want
to go out on your own I mean
I think night time you know probably not
but if the Sun is out you can just you
can go to a restaurant bar not a bar bar
but a restaurant bar and even bring a
book and it can be like an interesting
book and honestly who even cares if
you're really really reading it like get
the Cliff's Notes get the clips
get a book and put a cover on that's
like how to catch you man
I think
there's a place here called the hoxton
where it's like a bar and you
yeah yeah you know like
[Laughter]
bring by those terrible memories but
maybe go somewhere like that where it's
chilled out and you can do work and
there if you see somebody that you lie
find an excuse to initiate a
conversation like just sort of like
either you he goes to the bar you go to
the bar and you're like oh you know I
don't have the coffee near is great or
something like that just something yeah
so to potentially open a conversation
and see how he reacts because I think
you're right because what you what girls
have to overcome is is men's approach
anxiety and I'm running away that people
are meeting right now and it used to be
that people met mostly at work but it's
social media and I think Instagram is
the primary platform for that but I
actually I don't think that meeting
somebody on an app is a bad thing you do
have to show some social etiquette and
eventually meet in person but um I
actually helped a woman who is like not
very pretty I helped her to be very
successful on social media dating apps
more particularly hinged and the thing
about it is like if you're not like a
stunningly beautiful girl you have to
take professional photos it's the same
thing for men too have you ever noticed
the men that are the most successful on
Tinder maybe hinge as well maybe do get
professional photos so you'll get those
professional photos and then it changes
the amount of swipes you get pretty much
overnight so I told this woman this
because I was like we're not much of a
looker you're gonna have to go pay
someone to get pictures she went and she
got the pictures done she got flooded
with options and then none of the men
were good enough for her so I think
that's like a reality that you might end
up confronting and then you'll be like
maybe maybe I'm the problem again no no
like I do think that sometimes as a girl
when like like just from my point of
view it definitely is a problem when you
get all these messages because it's like
overwhelming and I know guys are like oh
boo who cried me a freaking River you
just you go through yes yes no no no and
then you get like a batch right and then
you make your plans with the badge there
you go what about messaging though so if
you get a guy's number or guy gets your
number then because that's another whole
thing too I'm the problem I'm gonna be
I'm a weak messenger and women suck at
texting I I would like to say I could
use some tips I could use some I am
today I'm weak the most fun I think for
me with text messaging is when it goes
from functional to quite flirty quite
quickly okay so if you can help if you
could trouble with the flirting oh here
we go I'm here to learn what are good
what are good flirty text messages I
mean I always try and move it in the
direction of like so hey you find out
what they're doing at the moment and
then be like um oh so are you are you
out partying tonight or are you at home
like a good girl or something I might
say something like that and then but but
then it's how she responds to that
because if she's like I'm at home
reading Dickens it could go like one of
two ways like well actually I'm home and
I'm crocheting and knitting at the
moment or it could be like I could be a
bad girl for the right man
but I think women's best bet like who's
stuck at flirting I think the best bread
is to be cheeky because if you're if
you're not fat and you're cheeky like a
guy be like oh she's flirty Okay cool so
how would you what sort of cheekiness
would you well I have to like go and
Rewind the hands of time and think about
like when I was first texting my husband
and stuff like that but no like
seriously like if if my husband was to
text me like are you home like a good
girl I'd be like whoa you know for the
right guy I could be a bad girl
I guess like I don't know it's hard
because you don't want to appear like a
hoe but if you're cheeky that shows like
a level of intelligence though I don't
think it's even the same thing sometimes
sometimes actually with the bad girl
thing so sometimes a girl might then
respond no I'm always a good girl and
she'll do the emoji with the Halo yeah
so there
and then you're like yeah yeah I believe
you you know kind of thing because she's
saying that but obviously you know
underneath is a kind of a so it's like
yeah emojis are good for women men don't
use emojis and honestly I feel like I'd
be put off by a guy that used Too Many
emojis in the first place you know but
it's to your benefits
sometimes I have a sexy face that's okay
yeah yeah I like the eyes emojis but
sometimes I feel like people don't get
it because I feel like it's like oh okay
firstly from the female perspective do
you get many guys who are sending like
unsolicited pictures of things in my
sometimes not that often I think
Instagram filters it out somehow yeah
but some of y'all stop it it's weird
yeah yeah it is weird but I think when
you're when you're chatting a little bit
particularly if you've been out if
you've actually been on the day and
stuff like that you know sometimes you
can send a picture no I'm not talking
about anything like like you know like
crude but like you you could I think you
could definitely send little pictures
and that could help to yeah I think I
know what you're talking about so like
you know you decide to get dressed up
maybe you're going to like an event or
maybe you've got girlfriends or
something hopefully you're not going to
the club I don't know but hey modern
women but if you're wearing like a very
form-fitting dress it's kind of sexy you
can do a cute pose like it doesn't have
to be nudes or anything like that you
can learn how to be a sensual woman and
just say hey thinking about you no well
yeah I'm not either girl like I don't
know I gotta be hormonal to be sensual
like that's when I'm ovulating
six months I've been trying to drop can
be turtleneck doesn't help today but
I've been trying I've been trying to
dress less like a grandma because no no
because I was like okay I'm 25 but I
well I'm almost 26 but I'm 25 now and I
dress like I'm 35. and I was I was
thinking I'm like
and part of it was I do wear my mom's
dresses yeah that had to stop
no I was I was so tired of it um because
Pearl did a branding shows I probably
gotta do branding shoes she did a
branding shoe in her mom's dresses I was
like that's not what I meant no
I don't know I I feel like I've I've
worked like on the channel so much that
I feel like I've just been like ow I
don't know getting a cute dress today
yeah that's not like fluffy but could be
form-fitting you want it like you want
it like tight enough to look like you're
a woman but Loose enough to look like a
lady yeah I think the problem well it's
because the comments lately have been
saying like
but they've been saying like oh she's
such like she has no like form and I'm
like I've been told I was like my whole
life I mean I'm like I think it's the
clothes I wear no I didn't even got a
great athletic body yeah no I don't want
to realize that the other day I'm like I
really don't help myself do I well we'll
figure it out don't worry about it don't
worry about it Mom I had to call my mom
the other day I'm like Mom I can't wear
your dresses anymore okay we're gonna
catch a man this way
laughs
that's what my ex-boyfriend he's like
why do you wear so many turtlenecks I'm
like I like turtles oh that looks good
let me ask you
um what do you think about a tacky
dressed woman
I don't like it
[Laughter]
quick I know yeah yeah well
no you you look very wholesome you look
very wholesome man no I think well when
you say happy dress women what I'm what
I'm imagining is a girl wearing like
super tight like short mini skirt like
super oh super tight super tacky loads
of makeup I personally don't don't like
that look at all I mean some guys
obviously do personally for me I like it
I like it much more
sort of ladylike innocent looking
perhaps uh a little bit more feminine
most stuff often is short but it's not
intention I'm just real fast and I'm
lazy I won't lie when it comes to
clothesline but if you were if you wear
sheer leggings or sheer tights
underneath yeah not not like okay it's
like sheer then you can wear something
short and you also look here yeah like
women interested in pantyhose I'm sorry
you can take your it could take your
outfit to the next level like that's my
opinion well what you can do though with
the with the messaging figures if you
were wearing putting on an outfit to
wear for a like uh like an event or for
even for the show or something like that
you could take a selfie with the picture
and send it to the guy and be like hey I
was just just trying this on what you
think kind of thing and that's a that's
the more subtle way of doing it I've
never thought to do that that's a good
idea yeah I think it's cute because I'll
send it to the guy that didn't touch me
at the hospital
I'll start by playing him up we need to
get him on the shower just like Grill
him like what is this
well I wasn't even sure if it was a date
I thought it was because he paid and he
took he told me you know well I didn't
pay because he didn't but then I was
like well maybe he just wanted some
people just start like you could tell me
from a guy's point of view I feel like
sometimes guys just think I'm interested
no I don't think it's that I think it's
like I think what I think the problem
I know that you're interested
women come up against the problem of not
only do you not initiate but also you've
got you've got the problem of the fact
that guys are afraid to initiate as well
before I learn more about about this
stuff you know I I would go on dates and
not initiate and then you go home at the
end of the day and you think oh [__] you
know and and yeah and it can hurt a
woman's feelings like sexual rejection
is very important to a woman
um I don't know why because we end up
doing the crazy spiral she's like oh
like was I not pretty enough was it not
good did I not joke enough what did I do
wrong he didn't initiate anything it's
really sad but yeah what you find is a
guy actually is that um I don't know if
you can show any light on this but
sometimes
um if guys don't initiate that the
window's closed what about like I don't
know I've heard that a lot of submission
and like suggestion can be done with the
neck of a woman do you know what I mean
well kissing on the neck is one but I've
heard of a woman like exposing their
neck to a man if that makes any sense my
body language body language is a key
thing so
um like well I don't know if the guy's
gonna necessarily pick up on that but I
guess you could throw that in I mean
it's the flickier the hair isn't it it's
a classic
you know if you if you just like touch
him on the arm and like Pottery practice
he's obviously doing
it's okay
no you're right this is actually really
interesting to hear things from like a
guy's point of view
yeah yeah no it's quite it's interesting
from the other way around as well made
me think about things
in a different way because because he's
got to be it's got to be difficult for
women though right as a man presumably I
mean
like I feel like
subscribing is common like a amongst
female athletes I think there's just a
group of us but like we're kind of
raised to be like tomboys and we've kind
of from raised to be like one of the
guys in a way and so it's like the the
girly stuff is just kind of like hard
for us yeah I think it's like this is it
because of my roommate Jazz it's like
very similar did she have similar kind
of thing yeah yeah because a lot of guys
be like oh you're talking to all these
guys and I'm like I don't know and we
just
the house half the time yeah yeah but
you were quite tomboys weren't you
um
like on and off I've only addressed
business casual uh because that was just
like my style and my preference but I
just found that women were really hard
for me to get along with and I know that
it always seems like oh like I just want
you know fatal male orbiters and stuff
like that but it's like if I gotta fight
with women to socialize with them on the
regular it takes a lot to read a woman
socially and I'm like forget it I'll
just hang out with the robotics Club so
like that was that was more so my route
and it's been effective but I think for
myself is um I'm feminine in some ways
and not feminine in other ways I like to
be of service to my community and things
like that but when it comes to a man
that I'm interested in I'm like very
soft for him and I think that that's
also it depends on like a kind of like a
man's masculinity as well because
there's some guys like you'll be soft
and feminine he's just like too socially
offered to get it yeah like I feel like
I'm agreeable and so like that's more of
like a feminine Trend very easy going
but I just was never like a girly girl
girl again and so like girls that like
they'll spend their day in the hair
salon go get their nails done I'm
worried about so much work yeah
a lot of effort I think you you kind of
like choose a path I think as a woman
because I always knew that if I
capitalized on my sexuality I I think I
felt like quick money has gone as fast
as it comes and so like for women it's
the same thing with sexuality if I lead
with my sexuality as a woman it's going
to be gone by the time that I'm 35. I
want to learn to rely on other things
but and the problem is like I feel like
my my brother's like I never wanted to
be looked at as like a hub or another
yeah be that girl you know what I'm
saying but I think sometimes like as a
girl you take it too far where it's like
okay they're not looking at all because
you're dressed like a nun yeah
like yeah I think it presents kind of
problems too because I think you choose
two paths right you either do like like
hoe or wholesome or whatever some in the
middle
um but it presents a problem because
then you'll be you know in relationships
or on dates and you really don't know
how to be a sexy woman like I'm not that
good at being sexy I will say that all
day long I'm great at being funny and
yeah like touching your arm but I'm not
sexy at all clothes are so good at that
yeah no no no if you could only choose
one pound
yeah it's like it's weird even though
she's a hoe everyone knows she's old she
still gets commitment from guys because
she's just so feminine and good at like
making them feel like she's had practice
it's not a problem
but it's like I'll see her do you think
I'm like wow she's just like she's so
good at like being sexy you know yeah
overall they don't but I'll see guys
like honestly chase her and fun over her
she's beautiful too yeah yeah I think
the thing is though on because you've
got people in the manosphere who who
talk about this stuff the whole time
they're like oh you know we don't want
women who a woman who's at home all that
stuff I think outside of that a lot of
guys don't probably don't really think
about it that much you know what I mean
they just probably don't even really
think about like body count or any of
that stuff yeah just like you know
I think it's like a benefit to be with
an older man for that reason because
you're like oh like you know I don't I
don't have to say like
um not sexy like I'm just I'm just young
show me the way show me the robes I feel
like they like that though I don't know
I could be wrong